[Music]
hello everyone and welcome uh to another
spectacular game from defeated world
team rapid Championship uh or rather
video world team championship that is
being played in the rapid time format It
Is by jinji versus Alexa shirov uh most
of you know uh by jinji for losing his
game to Dean Lira and in 2017 that was a
deemed dings Immortal game or even the
Chinese Immortal game as the game was so
spectacular if you haven't seen it it
will be the first link in the
description below uh you know you're
welcome to check it out even before
checking out this video a video or even
after the video uh because it's truly uh
uh you know I want uh uh Marvel at but
this game is a bit different and here by
jinji faces none other than the master
of the Mystic Arts Alexei shirov himself
playing board three for for team Spain
and it features a move that is not
something that comes to mind especially
in a rapid game uh so let's check it out
and why this movie is so incredible by
jinji with the white pieces opens with
4 with D5 by Alexa C4 C6 going for the
slav defense Knight F3 Knight to F6 and
now Queen to C2 with G6 and Bishop to F4
so a very very standard line we have
Knight to A6 and now Pawn to E3 uh sorry
if my voice voice sounds a bit weird uh
like I said my daughter just brings all
sorts of stuff back from the
kindergarten and uh you know it affects
your body in weird ways so E3 Bishop to
F5 attacking the queen and now Queen to
B3 putting pressure on the B7 pawn and
now Knight the B4 looks a bit odd
because it's a free Knight but you kind
of have to capture it because of Knight
to C2 check as the bishop and the Knight
are attacking that C2 square but this is
again all very very well known uh stuff
so Queen captures on B4 and pawn to E5
now opening a discovery on the queen and
attacking the bishop on F4 Queen
captures on B7 Rook to B8 with Queen
characters and C6 with check and Bishop
to D7 so giving back some material in
order to get full development in and
here white has two main ideas and both
of them are known uh one of them is to
move the queen to A6 the other one is
the actually capture on F6 but this is
such a brutal line uh that I absolutely
must show it so Queen captures and if it
was not played in the game in the game
Queen to A6 was played but Queen to F6
look at this queen captures Bishop
captures on E5 attacking the queen and
the Rook behind the queen queen to B6
now attacking B2 and it's again very
well known that you cannot capture The
Rook um so you have to play B3 first B3
Queen to A5 with check Knight B to D2
and now look at this Rook captures on B3
this is the only move that doesn't lose
the game for black so now the Knight
cannot capture because of check and a
capture some B3 is impossible because of
Queen characters on A1 with check so
Bishop to E2 preparing the castle and
now F6 Bishop captures and Rook the G8
uh White will castle and the now Rook to
beat you putting pressure on the Knight
and you can't really move the Knight
because the bishop on E2 will hang so
Rook 8 to B1 Rook captures black will
give up um
uh the The Rook for two knights captures
captures uh Bishop to F3 and now let's
say Bishop to E7 it seems like white has
too much material and black should not
be able to play like this but Black's
pieces are just so much better look at
this bishop captures and D5 attacks the
rook and now really no good Square for
The Rook uh if you play Rook to f8 then
Rook to B8 with check is just winning so
you have to play something like Bishop
captures here that Bishop is much too
powerful uh bishop countress and G8 and
now let's say Bishop F5 attacks The Rook
Rook to B8 with the check the game
continues but with two Rooks and the
bishop against the queen and two Bishops
plus the three Central pass pawns uh
White has uh all the counter play needed
in the world at uh well
uh make up for for not having a queen so
that's what is happening after Queen
captures an F6 but uh as Beijing she
knows who his opponent is his opponent
being Alexa sure of uh he knows that
shirov probably knows Queen captures an
F6 line much better than the queen A6
line so he plays Queen to A6 gets the
queen out of Harm's Way and now he
captures an F4 remember black still has
to recapture the piece so he captures an
F4 and now there is a game where C5 was
played and also Bishop to D3 is a normal
but here we have knighted the C3 bite by
yinchi and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game and it
doesn't take many moves to really blow
up the position look at this F captures
on E3 F captures on E3 and now Bishop to
H6 going after this E3 pawn queen to A3
stopping Black from castling and now
what can black play here
uh probably uh best for black is just to
play Bishop to f8 attack the queen and
kind of force this C5 move and white
will now have a pass Pawn on C5 but at
least black will be able to Castle let's
say Bishop to H6 but now uh White will
Castle Queen side black will Castle King
side and okay Rook D1 defends the bishop
but Rook to E8 goes after the pawn and
uh it's uh it's a fine position but uh
White should be much better black will
have some very nice attacking potential
but the the past C Pawn is just a past C
Pawn but instead in the game after Queen
to A3 Shiro played Bishop captures on E3
and it looks like a move you should be
able to play what could happen here well
I mean what could happen to you uh the
problem is the position is now
completely winning for by jinji but you
have to find the move that is so weird
uh that it definitely it's not the first
thing that comes to mind alright so feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure it out while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh well just
finding a an absolute brilliancy against
a true master of domestic arts and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is King the E2 this is the the
star move of the game and it is the only
winning move for white just to give you
an idea let's say you play Bishop to D3
and okay it makes sense you wanna get
your king into the game uh this bishop
here controlling all of these squares is
just too strong you can't Castle
kingside you can't Castle Queen side and
after a few more moves let's say captors
captures Queen to E7 now you're forcing
a queen trade because you're either
gonna threaten some very nasty
discoveries uh or you uh allow the queen
trade so let's say captures captures
Knight to D1 will attack the bishop
Bishop goes back and the game continues
white should always be a little bit
better but nothing spectacular it is an
extra Pawn after all it's a pass deep on
uh but uh that that's what happens if
you don't play the absolute us but here
by jinji played King the E2 and now the
what do you play the the thing behind
behind King to E2 that is so spectacular
is that it directly stops Queen to E7
Queen to E7 now is pointless and this
was Black's uh biggest move pretty much
on everything the white plays because
now white just captures it and wins the
bishop that's the point uh so what can
you do here okay you have to move the
bishop your Bishop is attacked Bishop to
F4 was played and now look at this Rook
to E1 now a white is threatening some
nasty discoveries with the King and also
you still cannot castle and also you
still can play Queen to E7 because now
King to D1 and now what are you gonna
play here so after Rook to E1 with
Bishop to E6 closing of the E file but
now King to D1 with d countries and C4
and the bishop captures on C4 the black
king still stuck on EA with Queen D7 now
this is possible but now uh happily
trades with Queen characters King
captures and now Pawn to G3 attacks the
the bishop here Bishop back to H6 and
now Rook to E2 will double up on the E
file uh Rook H the C8 finally getting
that Rook into the game and now Bishop
captures an E6 F captures and Rook H the
E1 attacking the E6 Pawn King to F7
offering a pawn and now King the C2
because if Rook captures here then you
allow Rook captures on B2 and you really
don't want to allow black all that much
activity
uh so King to C2 and now Knight the D5
putting pressure on the Knight and C3
Knight to E5 check King to G8 and now A3
uh with uh Rook the C7 Bishop to G7 is
also uh maybe maybe even a better idea
here but in the game Rook the C7 was
played now comes King to D3 Bishop back
to f8 and now Rook the C1 uh and here
the problem is uh yes you have put a
bishop on this diagonal sort of with the
idea of Knight captures spawn captures
and maybe winning the pawn the problem
is after Knight captures Rook captures
Rook captures and B captors you can play
Bishop captures on A3 but then Knight
the C4 attacks the bishop and also the
E6 Pawn so it's not really something to
uh to go for and a white would be
completely winning here so instead after
Rook to C1 Bishop back to G7 we have
Rook C to C2 now doubling up on the
second Rank and Rook to beat three we
have Knights the C4 uh now Rook to D7 we
have Knights the A5 attacking The Rook
and now best for black would be uh just
a trade here and hope for the best let's
say Knight captures on C3 Knight
captures on B3 Knight captures I need to
Rook captures I need to end not E5 very
nicely done as the king is on the same
file as The Rook uh with white or always
being better but maybe black can save
this however after Rook to B6 uh by
jinji just uh takes the entire game
Knight captures on D5 Rook captures on
D5 Rook to see it with tracking to F7
and now Rook the C7 with track King to
F6 now Knight to C6 and there is not all
that much you can do not is coming to E5
and The Rook is coming to F7 there is no
defense against this bishop to H6 was
played but now just Knight to E5 with
Rook the A6 and now Pawn the H for
taking away the G5 Square from the black
king and it was in this position on move
37 that Alexis Shiro resigned to the
game and what a spectacular victory for
baijinchi and an important one for China
at that taking down such a spectacular
alert player in in in in uh I mean in in
such a way and here you resign because
your king doesn't really have any
squares and now with G5 taken Rook to F7
will be Checkmate the only way to
survive is the is to give up the
exchange here with Rook captures on E5
but after the characters on E5 with
check and King F5 you would play Rook to
E4 again cut off the black king uh and
there is nothing black can do Rook to F7
will be Checkmate on the next move
unless white black plays something
really weird like tries to give up a
bishop then you will prolong Checkmate
for a few moves but I mean we do not
discuss that on this channel so yeah
after H4 a spectacular victory for
baijinchi and also uh for those of you
who are interested as this is not a game
from the finals the finals I have
already started the first match has been
played uh and the the second match is
being played now I will still not
discuss the results as we are going to
cover at the finals but I just thought
that I should definitely show this game
because
uh we do not see a move like uh like
King to E2 every day like Bishop
captures on E3 you you think there's
nothing white can do white is just
completely busted and then you see a
move like King E2 I mean wow
getting the Rook into the game because
without this you are not getting uh The
Rook into the game so also something
that might happen in your own game so
you will have uh this as a as an idea
maybe prepared that you can you know uh
sort of think outside outside of the box
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it truly a masterpiece
against Alexis shirov uh really nicely
done by jinji I would like to thank
Austin wheeler Ahmed Yousef anubakihal
clothes box and the Boonton Park uh Pang
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of defeated world team
championship until it finishes uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day